I can't
breathe excuse me
she here you go I'm getting out of the
car please help me who are you Grado I
took the keys out of us drunk she drank
an
entire
let okay come I'm coming I'm going to
grab my car my my stuff what's your
stuff you can't you can't AR me for
that if I'm
arrested
then talk to me then I'll come with you
I'm TR
talk she can't drive like this she
doesn't drink and it's not a
good she needs to least not drive get
her aneu the only one I see is
intoxicated as you right now okay that's
fine let her drive Dr let her drive drun
let her drive drunk don't be walking
anywhere 31 here let her drive junk
that's on
you dude do you understand that she's
come over here come back to the squad
car don't touch me like that I don't
want you to get hit I'm put I don't want
you to get I can walk walk back walk
back over here then walk back over here
walk back over here not no no you're
going to walk over to my squad card you
have hand arrest no I'm not I'm going to
detain you for your safety in a minute
here because theid I'm not safe right
here sir get I am not safe right
now drive drunk stop do you understand
that I called the cops St you're going
to get Hur you realize that I called the
cops you're going to get one of a that's
my phone do you understand do you
understand that I called the cops to my
mom and I took the keys from her you're
doing the wrong thing and
you give me that don't touch me
what is wrong with you get in the car
are you serious you're now detained
you're detained you're about to be
detained cuz you want to know something
you're hurting me you're detained I
didn't do anything you're detained okay
are you going to keep touching my stop
touching my stop it then get off of Meo
stop put your arms behind your back
wrong with put your arms behind your
back no I didn't do anything wrong I
some assist out here please yeah please
put your arm behind your back resist
psycho don't
man
is stop touching me stop touching me or
I'm going to see the you you put your
arms behind your back your son and
daughter you're put your arms behind
your back now you're so done put your
arms behind your back you don't know how
done you are put your arms behind your
back you're a resisting stop it no I'm
not I'm protecting myself put your arms
behind your back and I know the sheriff
right here so keep keep touching me sure
you do are you serious you're done you
keep saying that but you're still not
cooperating you touch me again you're
done you stop it stop touching me stop
touching me I'm being nice right I have
not touched you have I then don't touch
me you I have not touched you you're
going to get us killed in the middle of
the around get yourself I told you cuz I
am just literally trying to help my
mother and you are in car get in the car
then no I don't need to do anything dude
what is your problem I'm suing you I am
suing you if you choke me one more time
I am suing you don't touch
me you
Reas get in the car okay we want to
thank Morgan and Morgan for sponsoring
this body cam video I mean I think it's
pretty clear from the body cams that we
cover that it's not always safe out
there when you're hurt it can be
confusing it can be scary you don't
really know where to turn well Morgan
and Morgan is actually the largest
injury law firm in America and in a time
when you already have so much to think
about they're going to make it super
easy for you they have completely
modernize the process because you submit
your claim you sign contracts you upload
documents you talk to your whole legal
Team all on your phone that's it an
attorney is going to review your case in
just eight clicks also they have 4,000
support staff that can help you too
which is just amazing to think about and
in terms of price well you only pay them
if you win there's no upfront fee so if
you're injured and you want to join the
over 3 million people that call them
every year you can submit a claim at
www. forthepeople.com
ELC body cam or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your phone do you
have a reason to arrest me and took me
and H me battery yeah you think so cuz
you're battering me cuz I'm going to
suit and charge you don't touch me what
is wrong with
you car
I want the
sheriff hello please help please help
get in the car no ma'am ma' I haven't
done anything wrong look at his camera I
haven't touched
him would you help me no Len you listen
to me listen to
me I don't give
a don't ever touch again I'm not
touching your turn around you going to
break my wrist now are you serious put
your hands behind your back you're under
arrest for what for right now aggravated
battery to an officer oh really check
your camera on turn away from me and
stay right here okay is your battery on
get your of me yes be an audio thank you
thank you thank you you just hurt me
good all right you're done dude have a
seat are you
serious don't touch my face don't
turn towards me stand by I never text
you to begin with you touch me remember
you will not listen and comply have a
seat I don't need to I didn't do
anything have a seat into the
car Els you're stop resisting dud stop
grabbing a hold of me stop grabbing a
hold of me and put your feet in the
squat you are trying to hurt me so put
your feet in the car have a seat you're
under arrest put your feet in the car
have a seat now no put your feet in the
car have a seat now I will not you're
hurting me I asked you to please let my
arms I'm I am short you
understand
that's that's fine I'm not hurting or
doing anything wrong I'm
I'm grab it I I can't I can't look at my
I'm sh you I'm showing you am very
small so I cannot do that I understand
that okay what I want you to do though
you know the officer touched me and I
what I want you to do is put your feet
in the squad hurting me I all I'm doing
is holding your arms like to
see I am the commander of the cryst
commander you're smashing my face into
this you're smashing my
face here put your feet in there have a
seat
back yeah I see a
win this is
my arrest put your feet in the squad car
mid 14 trying to walk put your feet in
the squad car and have a seat put your
feet in the squad car have a seat car
okay we can talk but you have to get in
the car first okay I don't give but I
would like to talk to you okay we can
talk go in the car you know what dude
all I know
is that's fine that's fine in the
meantime you need to
have have a seat in the car we can talk
then yes we can talk have a seat in the
car we can talk we have to get in the
car first go we will I can get I'm very
well capable getting in the car and I
have blue and you are hurting me holding
on to your hands and your arms have a SE
in the squad car no we're Crystal Lake
SE what's your first name what's your
first name I don't need to tell you
that's what I'm still not arrested yes
you are you under arrest Samantha if you
don't have a seat let go of my hand now
let go of my hand now or what we're
going to put you in a in a restraint
device called the WFT just so you know
okay I'm waiting for the sh cuz I
haven't done wrong and I'm Amer sovere
have a seat in the squad car Samantha
mad Samantha have a seat in the squad
car be mad dude have a seat I haven't
done anything wrong that's why you guys
are cowards and you can't do anything
have a seat in the squad you aren't you
aren't you're a good person okay just do
me a favor no I don't need to okay I
haven't done anything wrong them you
want to you know where we're at at this
as a country we're back away there's a
as the yeah that's right let me talk to
a
boss I haven't G wrong you want to know
why she headbutted
me she was I saw it on video so be very
mad at she's on her elbow just enough
Roger yeah from your great
officer so this what being American
looks like all right you understand that
from this yeah I
guess well the only problem is my's all
the way up go my hand do not grab my
hand do you understand me do not put
your nails into my hand I have nails do
not stop touching me do not grab my hand
can you please help okay no you let let
him go have a seat get in the car have a
seat have a seat in the squad car the
sheriff's not coming oh now she's
kicking got her are you serious yeah
really really sir you seem like a
down hey B Missy are you
serious you understand I buckles down
there on the bottom sir can you look at
me in the eye for one moment let me just
get the people on yet you just had a
camera m that's why I it's defending our
country after I got
hit what think she take a
not good yep why are you doing
that camera's on for me
yeah you want me to yes St you're going
to lose right now and in court cuz you
guys bloodied my
lip and you blooded my for no reason any
officer am I in s sir yes or no do you
have to answer that one no I don't yeah
you do why don't you reread your cuz
actually you do you just done even
better than I
oh my
gosh right I feel the same
way you know what I am well I know
you're an idiot clearly
clearly know that you're
only well if they have to deal with
people like you for
sure dring driver fucking car
yeah like
that's
why cuz I have what cuz I have
what Loves Me Right loves
correct correct
yeah
yeah ah likewise
again well no you're not married cuz
you're this cuz of this right here
this is what you are yeah nobody's going
to come near this
yeah oh good God I couldn't even imagine
spending five minutes with
you oh yeah you'll never get there cuz
you won't even make it to
marriage right cuz no one want to deal
with
you for
that
well that's why you're not married yet
though cuz then they find out what you
really
are no I do not I'm years oh are you
serious
spinster all right keep talking you know
what at least I can isn't that like a
fifth grade comment if you're still
talking then it's so
funny my kids say shit like that at
least I can do
this oh I can't believe you're 31 and I
can't believe you should have reverse
the numbers you're 13 you hear yeah
yeah no it wasn't me but it's all on
camera you're too drunk to know that no
you put me in the car correct
you I don't know what your name is are
you going to are you going to coer I
don't know who you are but I know that
you shove my face into that door for a
reason so I'm the sergeant I don't want
to talk to you I don't care I'm the
sergeant are you going to cooperate with
us yes or no okay because if you don't
then we're going to take you stra call
my lawyer great we're going to take you
straight to County instead of and
they're going to let me out and you're
going to have to do a whole bunch of
paperwork do you
understand I'm
you tonight good luck dude you're two
actually you want to know something good
luck I don't I don't have to say shit
dude you my makeup is on your car I'm
tired of hearing talk my makeup is on
your car okay my makeup is on your car
so listen I'm going to get you out if
you fight with us we're just going to I
don't like you I don't care I'm not
going to touch anybody good I don't need
to touch anybody like you unlike you I
don't need to hurt other people to make
myself feel better okay we're going to
get you yeah I know that guess what you
have no other way to hold me it's not
your thinging it's not the law
goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye
no we need to get you out oh you think
you're so cool no you're not getting me
out if you could you would have me in
prison but you can't cuz you're a loser
that smashed my hand guess what I'm
going to get
you put you back in I'm putting you come
on we're going to take do you want to
know you're so s touch me again I I dare
you keep hurting me come on keep hurting
me
you understand what I'm saying I cannot
wait to see you keep doing it keep doing
it look at my elbows from these guys and
I haven't done sh that's why they're
letting me go ma'am you sure yes did you
not hear them say they're letting me go
no I didn't hear anything well then be
better my Sergeant's right here so yeah
that's your sergeant be better than him
cuz he's nothing that's why he's letting
me go all righty how we
doing doing okay no no what's the matter
I'm actually doing okay now that I'm
probably in your cuz this guy's
terrified okay well come on what the
sound Len it's okay can you have him
like maybe not touch me ever again I'll
tell you what you put your feet in a
little that's def I can do that can you
get a me
I nting me yep stop touching me there go
there you go what's your name stay right
there what's your name dude honestly
this I'm done with this have him stop
grabbing me like that know your name is
what's your name I'm not giving you it I
don't have to I'm not arrested I am not
arrested take care of it Searcher please
stop touching
me I'm not doing this all day dude cuz
I'm going to sue the out of this County
done the wall I have a he's honestly
hurting your hand on the wall I will do
that if you ask me to I said we asked
you to five times no he's hurting okay
your hand W I will put my hand on the
wall hand on the wall you understand
that stay there hand on the wall look on
wall dude I will literally put my hand
on the wall there I can only go this far
on the wall fuck dude I can't do that
have anything on you do you understand I
don't want problem do you have anything
on you no dude I have nothing on put
your hand on the wall keep it on the
wall serious she's pulling you away wow
and on the wall it shows how confident
this station is this is sad that's on
you again absolutely no except
my take your shoes off American
Sovereign citizen take your shoes off
okay thank you for asking me like a
gentleman in there yeah yeah okay what
about
it put your stuff in
here on the ground on the ground can
offic
on I wasn't being with to Oh no you're
fine I've been doing this job a long
time you're not going have my no I don't
want to hurt anyone's feelings that's
that's like the actually not all right
start again I don't know what your name
is but sure my name is
Samantha so curious KCK this foot back
for me sure LIF it up can I just put my
hands right here it's fine Lift It Up
Lift this up your officer rubed me up so
much I'm a little scared for me that
wasn't me yeah it was even it's all on
camera I was in the car officer
M that one m i e t u s all right yeah
you got
another let's do that let's go car about
their
own
samanth samanth
Samantha understand you got take those
Rings please can you just go away your
officers have me here so look you got to
take your rings I'll put them in here
okay am I your yes uh yes you are under
arrest
okay there
un to police off can you please tell me
what I'm arrested
for police off I haven't touched anybody
okay let's just get through this can you
take your R let's just get through can
you please take I have not touched
anyone can you please take but if you
could tell me why I will explain it to
you as soon as you take off your
property okay we have to get those rings
off fine you're doing your job I
understand but please keep him away from
okay he's over there I'm asking he's
over there okay let's just that's fine I
don't like cated men okay let's touching
let's all the Rings okay weirdo creep
dude right there on your
fingers and she's kind of hot hey like
right there that one why don't you like
talk to her she cute take this
off thanks guys except you know what
she's a got bigger dick energy than you
so you couldn't handle that you're queen
I'm being dead ass serious you're
beautiful can you take that out no I
really can't can I take it out no like
actual no I swear to God I'm not lying
to you I'm not a liar that's something
hold on just just stop for one second we
got to
except can you tell
me explain to you you arrested for two
counts I know but have you seen any
count of it on camera yes really I'm PR
sure that from come here your Sheriff
there what happened your Sheriff shoving
me into a caror who did the inside of a
caror by the way you sure and I cannot
wait to call my lawyer can I call my
lawyer yeah you can just a second give
us one second cuz you know that I don't
belong in here at all you want to know
that I called you guys also
I going
but sir we
got all the way down there you know what
though come sir I'm going to go right up
on
there also I'm
asking a question shut shut it we're not
talking really cool
thank you
Miss
you're what are you going to read my
right I'm just here to get you
information I me right it's Samantha
right I guess your first
name last
name that's your last name okay you
don't want to give me anything
okay so just
Samantha all right sounds good sounds
[Music]
good okay
um Dennis Meyer will have her
information he just I he just radioed it
did he okay like Granada something like
that
you want to know something that I have
men that I respect actually I like the
police but I don't like did you see my
teeth yeah they
look yeah they look um people hey uh Hey
Samantha notching them not touching what
yeah I'm a very Persona individual I
will did you not see me bow down to you
guys and you ask me to do what you ask
me to do I
a brly it's on camera can I um hold
listen so I got a I got a camera too
right so we we all we so can you see so
my name's my name's OB green I don't
yeah I don't I
don't oh
[Music]
okay and it was on a drunk driver that
you let drive so let's keep
going
who is this why because you fuck up this
County what do you mean you don't belong
in your place you don't have it like
what's that that for you're not
upholding it you took an oak right you
didn't
even no one in this bu can Me My Rights
first of all well we haven't asked you
any questions but you arrested me
you me my
right
we're going to get you out of here okay
all right well look okay all
right
okay sends up there look listen me okay
I know
me I know me though I will not be doing
anything to resist all right what I need
you to do is just put your hands back
behind your back
turn I'm okay turn around put your hands
okay all right
good right there is this your fucking
Sheri please tell me it's not your
sherff cuz I'm going to start a whole
shit sh no no it's
not no it's not no it's not him it's not
him it's not him you're okay I like you
actually like you you do really you got
a funny way of showing it yeah love oh
want that's nice that's nice I'm not
going to do anything here dude I'm
getting out what I'm going to bust out
of getting out here don't don't hey
look it hurts I
know they're going to lock it I'm not
doing I don't get ma'am honestly please
just go away I'm not trying to be rude
to you but I'm angry and it doesn't
deserve to be toen out on you you're a
beautiful young lady likewise okay
literally and I don't I everything that
I say I don't mean to you thank you for
for the hon people have been really mean
to me dude I'm not trying to be me
you're gorgeous you're sweet likewise
we're going to be stuck together for the
next little bit time that's fine I don't
want to be mean to you this I'm telling
you
likewise well she's she going top those
coer so she's going to slip those by the
way you tell me why you're in here for
non offensive crimes I small why don't
we uh do what dude I'm not getting out
of anything cuz guess what you're
letting me out anyway I know that's what
we have to go Samantha we're just going
to go over here
okay you know the trick with the
Handcuff ma' cross ma'am this is ma'am
cross them they they they might be all
right he's the one that bloodied my lip
I don't like him okay got it we're going
to we're going to walk this we're going
to walk this we got to go he's my boss I
can't not or else I'm going to get in
trouble so don't put me in that
weird got put this I'm put this over you
okay
right there we
go we're going to go right going to go
right over here all right I'm talking
about the
X are so sweet and cute you guys would
have treat him well yeah I I had I had D
she skinny arms but you're cute and
sweet and innocent don't be back don't
know oh my God these I'm not I'm
hearing you understand I'm not like that
like I'm not going to
I know listen I'm not I I don't think
you're going to run away but what we're
going to do is we're going to change out
handcuffs cuz I put I put them listen
time I put the mean ones on you and
you're not that mean okay so before
weedo anything I'm going to have the
officer the officer you like to the
right side okay we're we're going to
switch thank you I appreciate
it have such itty bitty teeny tiny hands
you know that I like your
outfit you want to tell
I wish I was out hanging out girl we can
we get and I make a that's what I try to
docking person you go put your
hands I really don't touching he's not
touching you officer the one that you
like the British guy to your cont
orang are you done okay I know they're
not really comfortable okay I totally
understand that all right
it's you don't understand comfortable
and like like my my WR might not come
out of these type shit if I'm in there
do you
understand okay we're going to start and
also and also
done big jump hang on guess what me
jumping in by myself was better than
what your officer
did with my face makeup on his fucking
window still I'm sure I'm going to get
the key down for you in a second all
right cash it up or
goodbye go thank you can you put these
back here
yeah can you please cop a trans um you
are arrested I believe for aggravated
battery right now I haven't touched
anybody resisting arrest I
think and they tell me they're letting
me
out okay um just so you
know
11 and I'm
be ug so I want to know why they just
told me I'm getting out right now yeah
tempor and I'm being
10 this is going to get really
ugly okay well my dear we just met thank
you not with you with your friend that's
cool no I know you don't have to be I
got human being I'm a human being a
million perc no I just want to know what
they have to tell me I was getting out I
don't my dear I was not back there so I
don't know what they've told you I want
to know why they said I was getting out
they're letting me out you heard that I
know you did I did not actually can you
ask them why they can you ask them that
I asked them um what do you mean they
said I'm letting you out right now when
they open the door maybe because they
knew that you were being
transported maybe that's I don't know if
they were if you felt like that was
misleading but I cannot speak for a I
don't give a I'm just I'm not scared of
J I just know my rights and I still
haven't been read them okay well no
one's talking my about what
[Music]
happened I do not understand
[Applause]
that
I
this my job is the best job in the
world
but I'm not acting like anything we're
good
right it's two uh charges of aggravated
battery and then one's going to be
resisting I
believe are you going to be good with
are you going to be good with us she's
fine with okay there's just uh some
other
officers okay very we're going to get
you out and get you situated okay just
give us like 2 minutes to find out
what's going on okay what's
that samtha Sam
Samantha me
grab you guys want to grab her first or
you we gra
her uh maybe you she's not in the ramp I
thought they said she was in the room
she was at one point we brought her into
uh our tdf it's been a very very crazy
hectic
night okay no we're not going well your
officer brasted my lip B so I'm just
well this is a whole new thing now okay
so we're not even going
to